hello and welcome to our conference call
MBA admissions insights considering a
joint or dual degree thanks for joining
us my name is Allison Davis I'm
associate director in the MBA admissions
office and I'm joined by my colleague
Mary Aleksey associate director joint in
dual degree programs hi everyone in the
next thirty minutes we'll be talking
about what to keep in mind as you
consider pursuing a joint or dual degree
we'll start by reviewing some of your
options as a joint or dual degree
student and then we'll discuss some
questions that you may find worthwhile
to ask yourself before pursuing a joint
or dual degree we'll wrap up by
answering some of the questions that
youse all submitted in advance so Mary
let's start off with the basics most of
this is on our website but let's review
it here briefly to begin can you tell us
the difference between a joint degree
and a dual degree yes so in a joint
degree there's a reduction MBA units and
some MBA units may either be double
counted towards both degrees or counted
towards the other degree in order to
graduate with a joint degree a student
needs to meet both sets of degree
requirements and I want to note that it
takes an additional one to three
quarters beyond the two years for the
standard MBA in contrast a dual degree
program is when a student pursues a
second degree with any other graduate
program at Stanford University that we
don't have a formal agreement with there
is a reduction in MBA units and this
allows a student to start earning credit
towards their other degree program I
want to note that there's no double
counting of units and students complete
the MBA in two years when they complete
a dual degree and there are even more
options right yes so beyond what's
offered at Stanford students may also
pursue degrees with selected
schools and other universities right now
our list includes public policy programs
at Harvard Princeton and John Hopkins
along with the Harvard Medical School
Yale Law School and Yale Medical School
and all of these are listed on our
website I want to note that we don't
have formal dual degree agreements with
these schools but we do in partner with
them informally to offer these as study
opportunities and what does this mean
for you it means you need to do the
legwork for these dual study
opportunities you will need to enquire
with each school regarding its policy
and its timeline for the programs and
why would somebody typically be
interested in pursuing more than just an
MBA I think in today's complex world
there's more and more recognition of the
intersection and interplay of business
with fields like law education
technology and medicine just to name a
few therefore we know a student's
interests and goals may span multiple
disciplines and we want to nurture that
by providing flexibility and an
opportunity to simultaneously explore
other academic areas so it may be
helpful to know that 21% of our current
MBA students are pursuing a joint or a
dual degree and be aware also there are
specific application instructions
depending on what type of joint or dual
degree are interested in for example for
the JD MBA the MD MBA the joint master's
in computer science and a few others you
would use sa B which asks why Stanford
in the online MBA application to support
your rationale for the joint or dual
degree while for the joint master's in
education you're required to upload a
personal statement in the joint degree
section of the MBA application again all
this information is on our website but
you should be aware of some of these
differences ahead of time that's
absolutely right and again I encourage
you all to read our website the GSP
website as well as the website
the other program you're interested in
because there are specific instructions
depending on the degree and in many
cases you need to apply separately and
you need to be admitted to both programs
so for example our JD MBA program with
the Stanford Law School falls into this
category and then in other cases such as
the joint master's degree in education
we will forward your application and
personal statement to the Graduate
School of Education so please do your
homework and read the website there may
also be different tests required for
example the MBA program accepts both the
GRE or the GMAT but the School of
Engineering will only accept the GRE for
master's degree programs in computer
science and electrical engineering and
if you're applying as an international
student the MBA program will accept the
TOEFL the Pte or the IELTS while the
School of Engineering will only accept
the TOEFL yes all correct and again
specific requirements for each program
are listed on the website and so you
just want to make sure you're familiar
with that Mary I think we should also
mention that applicants should be
mindful of when to apply the MBA program
has three application rounds with
deadlines this year on September 21
January 10 and April 5 however other
degree programs may only have one
application deadline typically in
mid-december the replied date which is
the date by which you must accept your
offer of admission may also vary so you
don't want to find yourself in a
situation where you have to decide if
you're accepting your offer of admission
to one degree program before you know if
you've gotten into the other degree
program yeah I really appreciate you
highlighting that if you're applying for
example to the computer science or
Electrical Engineering joint degree
programs I really recommend that you
apply to the MBA program in round 2 so
again this is something to be aware of
you want to make sure you check for each
degree program not only the application
deadlines but also the date that you'll
receive your admission
decision and the dates where you must
accept or decline your offer of
admission Mary let's talk about what's
your role in working with students who
are interested in pursuing a joint or
dual Decree mm-hmm so I work with both
current students and admitted students
for currently enrolled students I
provide academic advising and support
with navigating both degree programs
I also offer general advising sessions
for admins and students who are
considering applying for a joint or dual
degree and want to talk through those
options and just to be clear you work
only with MBA students once they're
admitted to the MBA program and with
current students who are pursuing or are
interested in pursuing a second degree
your your role is not to advise
applicants or prospective applicants
yeah I'm sorry that is correct I only
work with admits and students all right
now why don't we back up for a moment
and talk about some questions that you
out there should be asking yourselves as
you're getting ready to apply for a
joint or dual degree answering these
questions for yourself now can save you
time later in the application process
so of course first you need to ask
yourself is a joint or dual degree right
for you and how would you suggest people
think about that Mary mmhmm yeah and
this is important to spend some time
thinking about and I suggest that you
start at a high level so let's start
with a vision and I know that this is
gonna change for you many times but what
is your vision today for your future
career and do those career dreams
include opportunities or roles where a
specific degree beyond an MBA is either
required for you to get your foot in the
door or to be successful in that
position so you wanna you want to think
about that another thing to think about
is how important is having those letters
the MS or the MA after your name
sometimes it matters and sometimes it
doesn't
if the MA or the MS letters after your
name are not as important you want to
think about what's the content the
experience or the contacts that you need
to learn in
to pursue your vision I would also spend
some time reflecting on what you hope to
gain from pursuing an MBA and from
pursuing a joint degree and is there
room in this vision you have of what
your MBA is gonna be like for the
trade-offs that you're gonna need to
make when you're pursuing a joint or
dual degree program because there are
some choices that you're you'll have to
make and you can't say yes to everything
you also want to think about are you at
a place in your life where you can make
the time and the financial commitment to
stay for additional quarters beyond the
two years required for the MBA because
that can be significant so do you have
personal or family commitments that you
need to consider when you're making this
decision but I think all those are
important high level questions to think
about right next how do I decide which
joint or dual degree to apply to yeah we
have a lot of interesting programs here
and so I think once you have a clearer
sense of what's the subject area that
you're interested in go do your homework
I would do some research and deeply
explore both the structure and the
course requirements of the program and
the question to notice is when you read
through these classes do you feel
excited about it maybe not every single
class but you want to test for a sense
of alignment between the program
offerings and your learning goals so
trust your guide something else you want
to think about is your competitiveness
as an applicant so in general I believe
you should always throw your hat in the
ring for a degree program that you're
interested in that being said as with
the MBA application it can also be a
significant time commitment to pull
together a compelling application for a
joint or a dual degree it can take hours
to prepare for the exams requesting
recommendation letters or writing your
responses to an essay question so if
it's available I would take a look at
the admissions criteria or statistics
for the student body of the program
you're interested in to assess are you a
viable candidate for this program and
would this be good use of your time
and I want to highlight that right the
advantage of doing a joint or dual
degree program is that you're going to
blend your learning and you're going to
be more efficient with your time on
financial resources but the challenge is
that you have to prioritize and make
some choices around what is it that
you're coming here to learn what's the
experience you want to have and how can
you fit that into the allotted time that
you have good advice okay
people should also think about timing
and ask themselves should I apply for a
joint or dual degree when I'm applying
for an MBA or wait until I'm already a
student at Stanford mm-hmm it's an
interesting question so if your decision
to come to Stanford depends on being
accepted to both degree programs then
yeah you need to apply for those both in
advance of enrolling but if you're not
totally sure and you know you want to do
the Stanford MBA regardless of whether
you are accepted into a second degree
program you could wait and you could
wait and apply during your first year at
the business school to the other degree
program and then make your decision how
many students do apply after they're
already here mm-hmm
about half of our students pursuing a
second degree do that so fifty-fifty and
just as a reminder the application
requirements like test scores essays etc
all of those things are the same whether
you apply in advance or whether you wait
until once you're a student here last if
I'm accepted to a joint or dual degree
how does the timing work which programs
should I start first do I even have a
choice so my famous answer it depends it
depends and I would refer you to the
website to our website to see kind of
the pathways and options for example
medical school school students always
start at the med school and most JD MBAs
start at the law school but other
programs such as I per the Masters in
public policy or the MA in education all
of those students will start at the GSB
first for programs like electrical
engineering and computer
it's more of a personal preference of
where do you wish to start great Mary
alright let's move on now to answering
audience questions and again thanks to
so many of you for submitting questions
in advance so first question what are
the financial aid opportunities for
joint and dual degree students and how
do they differ from regular MBA students
yeah this is a really good question so
for students pursuing a joint or dual
degree here at Stanford um you're
treated the same as an MBA only student
when it comes to determining financial
aid eligibility and financial aid here
is awarded based on need and one thing
to think about is depending on which
degree you are pursuing it may be best
to start at the GSB first as we will
provide financial aid including
fellowships for the entire time it takes
to complete your joint degrees this is a
discussion you can have in more detail
with our financial aid office after
you've been admitted let me also note
for those of you considering study
opportunities outside of Stanford you're
eligible for financial aid from Stanford
only during the time that you are here
for the MBA and so the other institution
would be responsible for any financial
aid you're receiving while you're
attending their program and so you would
need to apply separately for financial
aid from that institution right our most
joint degree students people who studied
related fields in undergrad mm-hmm
so not necessarily our technical degree
programs like computer science and
electrical engineering tend to have the
most direct correlation between
undergraduate and graduate experience
but other programs such as education
hyper or public policy all have a
broader spectrum of undergraduate
backgrounds well schools confer with
each other during the joint degree
admission process Allison I'm gonna
defer that one to you okay sure the
admission decisions are made separately
we do ask on our application form if you
have applied or are considering applying
to a joint degree and
degree so we are aware that you may have
applied to another program for dual
degrees students need to apply and be
accepted to the other program separately
and then notify our office in any case
if you're admitted to the MBA program
and any second degree program whether
it's a joint or dual degree at Stanford
or one of the selected study
opportunities outside Stanford Mary will
be available to answer your questions
and help you map out your schedule of
how you'll pursue the two programs next
question are there a specific number of
spots available for each joint or dual
degree program there are some programs
that have MBA specific cohorts so in
particular education and eat I per will
typically accept approximately 20 to 25
students each year the cohorts for the
other programs are really based on who
they want to accept so there is no set
number okay
can you discuss the computer science
joint degree and the various careers
that people who have graduated with that
degree go into mm-hmm so the CS joint
degree is a young program we're going
into our third year of existence and in
speaking with our current students there
is something I want to highlight for all
of you so students tell me this is not a
program for students interested in being
product managers what this is is a
program for students who wish to take a
deeper dive into a specific area within
computer science so I would advise you
if you're thinking about this program
please go explore the computer science
website and take a close look at the
areas of specialization because you want
to make sure that what they're offering
matches your interests and regarding
careers we actually only have one
graduate of the program at this point so
I don't really have data yet to share
about the career paths and Mary we
should also probably mention in terms of
undergraduate backgrounds for computer
science they really do need to have a
Nicolle undergrad degree is that right
yeah they should be highly quantitative
or technical so computer science applied
math engineering but something in that
that John Wright or physics I guess is
one that's I think is acceptable so
again take a look at their website but
they are looking for people with to be
competitive applicant you do need to
have a technical undergraduate degree
all right next question if I joined a
joint or dual degree program what I
later be able to drop one and focus on
the other or do I have to follow through
with both no matter what yeah this is
also look at it depends question but let
me say in general it's a difficult
position to be in if you're in a joint
degree program and you're not sure if
this is the right path and that's why
doing your homework now on alignment and
program fit is so important and in
general if a program is no longer a fit
it's likely that you would be able to
withdraw however depending on the timing
there can be significant implications on
your degree progress and graduating in
time so this is a decision to be made
carefully and is definitely a decision
that students would consult with me
before making and I think this might be
an example of a situation where you
might wait to apply once you already MBA
student here and you kind of get the lay
of the land and what the workload is and
then apply as a first-year student to
that other degree program yeah I agree
how demanding is it to take a dual
degree if the second degree is from
Stanford also and this person is
thinking of the MA in either education
or public policy mm-hmm so I want to
delineate a difference between demanding
versus commitment and challenging so
taking on a second degree it's it's a
commitment and if you're fully aware of
the ramifications of that choice in the
beginning it shouldn't be a painful one
from an academic perspective all of our
students have been
academically successful in our joint
degree programs so what you're really
navigating in regards to demanding or
challenging is what electives are you
going to take when and how do you spend
your time outside of the classroom when
you have homework class preparation and
other activities that you want to do so
it's really more around priority
management and time management than it
is about like overall demanding what
about the more technical degrees like
electrical engineering or computer
science how demanding are they yeah
those are I would consider more
demanding especially in regards to time
so for example students have shared with
me that one class can sometimes be 20 to
25 hours of work outside of the
classroom Wow
so this is not a degree for the faint of
heart right okay
may I apply to a joint degree after
being accepted to the MBA program is it
more competitive than applying to the
regular MBA program so I think we've
spoken to this already that yes you can
apply after and it is not more
competitive than when you're applying
during the NBA admissions cycle as
mentioned earlier the application
requirements are all the same regardless
of when you apply for programs that
require travel between two different
universities how well can students
really create a strong connection to the
Stanford community so when you talk
about connection to the community I
think what we're really talking about
are student relationships and from what
I have seen students have been able to
maintain a strong sense of connection
through these relationships what I also
notice is students tend to be fully
immersed and present in their actual
location so if they're here at the GSB
they're fully here at the GSB and the
same is true for the other program and
so if you're at your other institution
you're taking full advantage of the
Reese
and the people that are there so I don't
think you have the same sense of missing
out here and all of our students still
have access to all the GSB s online
resources and also staff are available
to connect over the phone or video chat
so I think students can remain as
connected to the GSB as they want to be
students have told me that it's really a
chance to enlarge their own community
and they pretty much end up sort of
doubling their network at not only to
different universities but to different
departments on campus yeah another
question here I would love to learn more
about how distinct or integrated we
should make the applications especially
with regard to the essays is some
overlap in our responses to the essays
okay I'll go ahead and answer that one
MBA admissions only reads the two essays
that are required for our application
and those are this year what matters
most you and why and why Stanford we
would expect that you would address your
interest and your rationale for the
second degree in the why Stanford essay
the other degree program typically does
not have access to or read the essays
required for the MBA so yes there will
of course be some overlap in the essays
as as their first separate audiences if
I'm not quite sure if this person is
asking how much overlap there could be
between the two MBA essays the what
matters most you and why and the why
Stanford that's really entirely up to
you both essays are read by the MBA
admissions office how distinct or
integrated the two essays are of course
depends on what you're writing about so
for example if what matters most to you
relates to your reasons for pursuing two
degrees there there could be overlap in
the topic if what matters most to you is
distinct from your interest in the two
degrees there may be no overlap in the
essays
here's a question about JD MBA for JD
MBA students do you have enough time to
establish strong relationships with both
your GSB and Stanford law school
classmates which we we sort of addressed
but any further comments there Mary yeah
I would just say yes there is time in
part because students typically spend
one full year at least immersed at the
law school and then another full year
immersed at the GSB so you are able to
connect with your colleagues and I think
right in the blended years is where it's
a little bit more challenging because
you have two communities and two full
sets of activities as options here's a
question about masters in education can
I apply separately to the MBA and the MA
in education so in case I'm not admitted
to the GSB I can still pursue the MA in
education if I am able to apply
separately the same year and I am
admitted to both degrees can I pursue
them as a joint degree this is a good
nuanced question so the education that
MA and education MBA program is only for
students who are admitted to both
programs so if you are not accepted to
the GSB you would need to apply to a
different program at the Graduate School
of Education
and I would encourage you to visit their
website and they'll have more
information on the options another
common question we get Mary about School
of Education is if the joint masters
with education includes teaching
credential and it does not correct yes
that is correct
although the Graduate School of
Education offers a teaching credential
it is not part of the joint master's
program well pursuing a dual degree burn
out students and this student is
student MSN computer science so let's
talk about what causes burn out in my
mind burn out is taking on too much
without the resources to make it
sustainable
so yes the computer science degree
program requires extensive hours outside
of the classroom and that means you need
to be willing to prioritize and make
trade-offs in order to find a
sustainable path but again I spoke about
this earlier if there's alignment
between the program and your goals then
there's a connection and so those
trade-offs shouldn't be too difficult to
make for students who are interested in
doing both the MA and a master's in
public policy at Stanford is less than
the current average work experience for
an MBA which is four years average
acceptable so if somebody has three
years or two years is that okay this is
the emissions question so again I'll
take that there is no requirement for
the number of years of work experience
for the MBA program or for any joint or
dual degree program as far as I know
mm-hmm how many students per year pursue
a degree with the Harvard Kennedy School
concurrently with an MBA from the GSB
and if somebody is applying to the MBA
program in this coming cycle would they
be applying to start in 2018 mm-hmm
so we have approximately 10 to 15
students each year that are doing the
program with the Harvard Kennedy School
and recommendation in regards to
applying for the GSB is that you should
be applying for the year that you wish
to start and so somebody would apply to
Harvard Kennedy this coming cycle and
then they should wait until next year to
apply to the GSB okay got it
what have graduates of Stanford's joint
masters education accomplished as a
result of their experience at Stanford
so I think what you're asking here is
what careers have these students gone on
to let me give you a sampling of the
areas so they've gone into tech startups
international schools charter schools
higher education administration and
education investing just to name a few
okay well we're almost out of time if
you didn't get your question answered
today please feel free to contact our
office by email or phone to ask your
questions before we go Mary any words of
advice for our listeners today yeah so I
think pursuing a joint or dual degree
can be a wonderful opportunity and it's
something to be done with purposeful
reflection and intention given that for
many of you coming to graduate school is
a one-time occurrence it really makes
sense to be efficient with your time to
maximize your interdisciplinary learning
and to make use of your financial
resources so my best piece of advice for
you is try to get as clear as you can on
what you want to learn and then just
make sure that the program you're
applying to meets that needs so your
expectations are realistic and aligned
and hopefully they're met good luck on
that thank you Mary
and thank you to everyone out there for
joining us an audio recording of this
conference call will be posted on our
website in the next few weeks the
previous three calls in our MBA
admissions insight series are already
posted there so take a look at those the
current application is now available on
our website again there are three
application deadlines September 21
January 10 and April 5 on our website
you'll find videos webinars and a
calendar of events offered both on and
on campus and around the world we look
forward to meeting you online or in
person good bye for now